the Joe Rogan experience when you refer
to like how you fill your head up like
what you fill your head up if it's just
like junk and sugar and how much time
you have to process stuff one of the
things I've noticed and it's kind of
started it's begun to startle me a
little bit is I used to find in social
situations that I would be very
interested in letting people know what I
thought about stuff mmm bee bee [ __ ] I
had no business talking about and I
think that you see people like when you
see like someone who's older and we have
this idea that like old older wiser
person and they're just taking in
everything and they've learned to be
quiet yeah people don't really think
about the fact that maybe they're just
like sick of hearing themselves talk
that - do you know the saddest thing is
those an old [ __ ] hey I want to say
yeah baby I think I you need to explain
like it's old racist Oh an old dummy the
old person who has like ridiculous
archaic views of women or ridiculous
archaic views of society and culture and
immigration and all these different
things like a person without nuance an
old person who's not learned from the
humbling experiences of life and has not
looked at himself in his own folly and
and has a humorous take on it
description you paint a flattering
portrait yeah man I think about it a lot
I don't want to be that guy yeah I
encountered a dude like that not long
ago where we decided that we're gonna
take our kids like we're gonna take our
kids out to eat and I don't want to have
to deal with any kind of like added
noise and I was trying to I wanted to go
under there's like this like truck that
sells tacos it's called like El Rodeo or
something let's go to that taco truck
and eat cuz I'm not talking about in
deal with anybody
my wife convinced me to go to this brew
pub so we go down the group I'm kind of
like in the I'm already pissed off
because I'm like kind of half mad at my
wife for making us be in a potentially
social situation and I'm sitting hearing
this old man walks past me on his way
out of the restaurant and he's gotta do
not resuscitate bracelet mmm okay he's
like he's got a little walk you know
those four pegged canes he's got a four
pegged cane
it's probably nickname for that and
do-not-resuscitate bracelet and he walks
out with his wife girlfriend whatever
and she wanders off and he's just
standing outside the restaurant and it's
just killing me to know what that's all
about so I grab my older boy and we walk
out and I'm like you know I couldn't
help but notice you have bracelet says
do not resuscitate what's that all about
you know and I said do you just feel
that if it's your time it's your time
and you should and you don't want modern
[ __ ] - like interfere and sort of what
you imagined to be like the way things
go and he explains to me is like no I
goes ecigs like he's pissed he's already
pissed
he was probably pissed before I talk to
him he's like I don't want an oxygen I
don't want CPR I want nothing and he
goes because I was having a heart attack
and they resuscitated me and broke two
of my ribs
therefore I don't want to be
resuscitated
I remember thinking like but but you
were having a heart attack
like the tradeoff seems minor yeah but
just like he was he was so kind of just
pissed that they broke his ribs that he
couldn't even see I'm like another way
of looking at it would be that they
saved your life but he said he just
wanted to suffer his heart attack with
ribs intact and at this point would just
rather die than have broken ribs that's
there or something like I don't know I
couldn't even begin and almost like I
thought he was interesting also that I
didn't think he was interesting anymore
such an unfortunate perspective because
if he said it's not a great story but
you said I'm saying no it is a great
story because it's like if he said hey I
had a good time it's you know there's
only enough room for so many people
that's what I thought I was gonna get
you know that's what I thought I was
gonna get in forward to meeting Jesus
yeah I thought I was gonna get that so
much so that I brought my boy with me oh
boy because when I was a little kid my
dad would go out of his way to have
weird people over to the house yeah I he
it was important to him to expose his
kids the weirdos
so I was like come on son we're go talk
to this crazy old man with the
do-not-resuscitate braceland you like
learn something about life but that
might not never mind never forget that
guy there's a trade-off of broken ribs
for life broken ribs takes like a couple
of months and you're fine yeah you might
be like dude you're at a brewpub with
your girlfriend she's going to get the
car you don't want to continue this bike
like this not bad not bad
[Applause]